موجه غضب في ليبيا هو سبب بث مباشر لولاده
القيصريه على فيسبوك فما الذي حصل بالضبط
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فيديو اثار غضبا واسعا في البلاد وذلك بعد
ان قام طاقم طبي بتصوير امراه وهي تجري
عمليه ولاده قيصريه المقطع المصور اظهر
المراه داخل غرفه العمليات في مستشفى
حكومي ليبي بعد ان وقع تقديرها مرفوقه
باحد الاطباء الذي تقفل باخراج الجنين من
بطنها
[موسيقى]
هذا المشهد الذي بث على صفحه المستشفى في
فيسبوك اثار سقطا واسعا تجاه تصرف
الطاقمين الطبي والاداري للمستشفى وندى
نشطاء التواصل بعدم احترام ضوابط واخلاق
المهنه حرمه المريض والقيم الانسانيه
والطبيه
[ضحك]
رئيس اللجنه الوطنيه لحقوق الانسان بليبيا
شدد على ان نشر اداره المستشفى للمقطع
جريمه علنيه داعيا وزاره الصحه لاتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه العاجله وردا على هذه
الانتقادات حذفت اداره المستشفى الفيديو
مؤكده انما ثمن نشره جاء بعد اخذ الاذن
كتابيا من ولي امر الحاله لكي يرى اهلها
مولودها الاول وهي بعيده عنهم استدعى ردا
من ناشطه السياسيه قال فيه انتم مستشفى
حكوميه ولستم تقدمون برنامج لما يطلبه
المستمعون
[موسيقى]